yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
be
breathing I can't Ste my
face
moving oh a breacher there this a a
appear
yep that's in Morgan
making the
turn
where the columns
are all right pulling
up
no how no
how Camas Camas
Camas police search for come to the door
police search for come to the door dos
dos dos police search for it coming down
the
stairs you're good man come here put
your
up okay the door just come
down coming she's on is a permanent bed
come out is it a permanent bed huh
splits up down
D got the bottom splits up and down
spits up and down baby on the first
floor all right just going to hook left
to the kitchen all
right go
ahead kitchen's clear moving
up
got
you I see CLE yeah what I can see is
clear ready yep I
go you good
J you got the comment I'll push
forward we're good in
here
look
it's clear all right put a push
back bathroom
bathroom
clear
clear clear up
here
get up
here I'm with the baby not going
to find out what our is we have to open
this
surprise can you help
[Music]
say
what do you
think let's sing our d song D is the
[Music]
sound you said D and the D came out
great job fig it out because duck and
dinosaur and dog
I'll start with the letter d and these
are both this is an upper and
is yeah I know lots of things good
[Music]
job hey guys coming
out
[Music]
dinur
is somebody in
trouble okay you the only one in the
house
[Music]
yeah my aunt so this is my move your
feet apart from me please my sister and
my mom are they in no they're
all can I your
pocket
mom you know when I do this podcast I'm
conscious about what I wear this is not
by accident I want to be presentable to
all of you and there is a place that I
want to tell you about where you can
find clothing to buy and a whole host of
other things to buy it's called deal
dash what is that glad you asked deal
dash is an auction website it's been
around for 14 years and they are now a
proud sponsor of sidebar they have
awesome deals super exciting auctions
the way it works is you buy bids and
then you bid on things that start zero
doar everything on the site starts at Z
and they gave me Jesse Weber from long
crime sidebar $100 which came out to
$770 and let me tell you when I say I'm
bidding hard right now on these psycho
tuna bathing suits I mean Summer's right
around the corner I want them no I need
them okay so what's the catch well you
got to pay upfront to bid so for
instance here after you sign up they ask
you to buy 400 bids for 30 bucks which
means you can bid 400 times in any of
their auctions and by the way they have
some seriously quality items like this
brand new jeep that someone won for
$1,875 a Nintendo switch for
$22 deal dash for everyone no some of
the auctions can take hours or even days
on end so you need to invest time for
bidding but if you like bidding on
auctions and you've got the time on your
hands to figure out how it works you can
get some pretty sweet deals so check out
dealdash.com when you sign up use my
promo code law crime 100 and you get 100
extra free bids on your first bid pack
purchase and if you don't win an auction
using these bids or you don't like it
for any reason contact deal dash you get
your money back no questions asked on
your first bid pack purchase so the
downside is really limited it's worth a
try now once you're done finishing this
episode of sidebar of course you can
check out dealdash.com laww crime1 100
other the baby anybody else in there the
dog the dog
yes I can you can call her she's at
work's yeah I'm haven't been here in
five years I'm
ter any you could grab my shoes from the
front door
there her phone go ahead yeah yeah I can
give you my password if you want to call
her we'll get it we'll
get um his respiratory therapist might
call he's in there des and breathing so
I'm your baby yeah I was bulling with
his ventilator when you got start
knocking they also have a ring
Bo never I've never been involved with
cs before at all but I have to say F I
have a baby on the ventilator fair
enough I almost started screaming
running I don't know what I know like
you can't
run this is my first time in handcuff to
how are you related to the home my aunt
my mom's sister is anybody in town going
to be showing up in the next hour or so
well I don't know what time they get off
but they'll all be home
today so like my aunt and uncle this is
their house what are those the Jennings
yeah Rita Jennings Coke Jennings they
have a son named p in the they have
another son Nam they want to put her in
the car not be idea
and then my mom lives here my mom and
sister got our rehab what's your mom's
name Lizzy I Lizzy Justice is her legal
name she about Al Spencer
Aly I figur this is for my mom my
mom's so we're going to bring up we're
going to bring up a car we're going to
have you sit in the car for the time
being all right downstairs dogs locked
in
let me check see if they blck
these and and the thing is we may have
once they clear that we're going to
probably
[Music]
May does does he need an ambulance now
yeah uh my car my car is stuck up there
behind our car cuz it's
so the baby having respiratory issues
yeah we can look at
his do me a favor hey is that is that
place take do me a favor take the cffs
offer and um let's call Life
Care we can they and stuff okay so she's
going to on the ha up you can walk with
me they have that clear we'll go down
and we'll have light is
that I know they can I know I don't know
what they're doing I don't want no
part did you come
yeah coming in right
now you
follow
last name or what it's
uh got a there's a see there's a Nick
there's a Payton there's a Jordan
there's a Marin
aita why don't you my mom speaking to
here come here real quick and let's T to
your kid
first I know I
know um are you able to open my phone
and see what for the
next yes it's be under
Adam the
password you said Adam is it a message
yeah on
text he said if you can send me a short
video of like 30 seconds of his
breathing that's what you want to take
the video just this
belly or we
can what's that who's Adam he's not a
respiratory therapist a respiratory
therapist yeah take care what he go yeah
or could you just FaceTime
him if you want to give her her phone
real quick and if she I'll just FaceTime
him I'm just going to tell him what
happened just call can you call him yeah
okay call
him
does he typically do that behavior when
he's yeah where he was in the hospital
for a year he just got out and where
like the lot was always
[Music]
very
good okay he's busy so if you want we
can just go
to we'll just get a Des for
you do what you usually do with a child
okay but thank you guys but him being
like that that's normal to you oh yeah I
mean just the breathing isn't normal but
like he's okay okay all right that's all
I want to know I just want to make sure
he's
good no I don't know what that thing or
something it's okay I know you got to do
what you got to do you don't know what
you're going we didn't know you were
going to be I'm from hot Kentucky an
hour I can
tell um once we get this thing going you
can just sit
there
so the little one she's giving it like a
what would you call it a breathing
treatment no I just I'm just W on
my all right these these guys are medics
okay okay so what it is is recently okay
he has he born at 26
weeks and name
usually not
now I don't have any traveling
[Music]
oxygen recently had Runo virus three
times in two months
andon we both got I'm pretty sure we
have run virus again cuz we got like
same to me here and then yeah feeders
last four day I was able to hang get
them down one got up
105 the first one I was able to get it
down with a double do
T fever went away and out Shi he just
now he was Contracting harder okay R
turn the best up 16 and that's getting
better okay but he hasn't seen the
doctor or anything so take absolutely
you want a squad called yeah my car and
I don't have his car seat it's a rental
car acting normal for movement what's
going on yeah everything's normal okay
all right color and all that it's just
the breathing is something up the Brea
working a little harder than normal the
breathing okay how old 17 months old
should be one yeah should be one in a
month
correctly
one not my back
bag mail huh mail
mail
[Music]
I really don't know anyone they talk to
though no I know like the family how
long have you been staying here I've
only been here a few days we just came
for Christmas and then we just stay an
ex week and stuff we're supposed to
leave today but then he got to
who's adding the picture so that is Rita
and that is co there's also a picture
frame here is it
Coca-Cola yeah yeah oh he's a Coca guy
yeah see that's R good I don't see any
other pictures anybody I say I can point
out everybody on that once it changes so
is this their house time so is that your
house this is D's house and
Mars okay gotcha it's just
I and then my mom and sister stay in
that room me and sleeping in
here and RE CO room is the one directly
under us right here and then pton is
that other bedroom that's their son he
works
[Music]
with this is actually too
I
[Music]
some
right that's so cool that watch Person
scary but cool what's that huh like SWAT
I like I've SE videos of it on you you
like that's what was sit watch when I
eat stuff
I yeah I wouldn't like it either
buddy it's
[Music]
okay good and clear
yeah not fun for
you uh what what do you guys think like
just the contract that's me like he's
satin fine but he's Contracting hard if
you feel like he's breathing harder than
he normally does you would know him
better than we would um he's if he's
belly breathing and he's working like
actually trying to draw I just
understand like contract car but I don't
understand that part well kids do
compensate very very well yeah um so
just to be safe I mean I would recommend
him getting checked
out I know
was falling down